but when I started there was no training
there was no self-defense somebody
pulled a weapon on you you weight him
and he would somehow did you get into
the security business my dad was a
doorman at a venue in Darwin and as a 17
year old lad
I got him I'm amazed well no I'm having
a few drinks and there was a big fire
side and it just got bigger and bigger
the doorman was struggling when you
stood watching tables and chairs and
bottles being thrown and you know you
danced around a little bit trying to do
his job
you see him people getting hit that
happened nothing at all to do with the
original argument um you feel that
you've got to get involved and seeing a
young girl and get hit full on with a
bottle was what tipped me over the edge
you made me go in you just lashing out
eyelid and it's in front of you grabbing
whoever you count dragging him to the
door getting them out and it was after
the when I stopped her picking up all
the broken bottles glasses furniture was
leaning against the bar thinking I could
do that job
nah Paula get paid and then the owner of
the venue came over Ken sponsored ad
said start you a lot on the Doria and
the dad said no I don't want him doing
this job I think it was cuz my dad said
no I went yeah I'll do it
it was a case of if he can handle
yourself and do the job you handle
yourself and do the job and that was
that was basically how he's died 30
years ago you know what about yourself
well I left the police is a volunteer
when I was a righty enough I think we
know what to do when I got out and one
of my mates Matt he said when he joined
me on the doors
I fought a bit nervous but I followed
him for a shift I'm paid obviously and
see what was all about and he locked me
in his boss liked me and brought me on
and the Adrenaline's matched to be fair
tell me about your first shift I'm
involved on a little little Irish pub
called the Fiddler's elbow and the
doorman next door was having a lot of
trouble but dad's a bit of a man's man
he was proud dead proud to be doing it
and I was worried what if I make a
mistake and my dad is and it's a bit
disappointing for me really there's a
bloke with bottlings and I can't behind
him I've grabbed him from behind and we
sort of run by the chest and walked out
backwards with him still with bottle in
hand it's one of those things where fear
sort of sinks and your adrenaline kicks
in and you just do things without
thinking what about your first shift
back in those days is a bit wild there
was no you know there was no rules as
such not only did have my dad watching
me and his team watching me so obviously
I felt I couldn't put a foot wrong first
little scuffle what night the door saw
stop stop back and let me go into it on
my own to separate it that's a complete
young lad fine
I think see that big brawl had brought
it down to scale two guys fighting
compared to 30 or 40 people throwing
things at each other and trying to kill
each other it's a bit of a difference
and at least I knew I had a team behind
me if it did go wrong I wasn't on my own
what's the biggest point you've been in
a bit of a few over the years and I
think well the major fights I've ever
been in a very well-known venue in
vaudeville I wasn't actually working the
door there and I was out in what we call
the bowel boss we got round on the
venue's chuckling melot's wall through
the doors and it was ma'am absolutely
I've never seen anything like in her
life big venue
massive capacity and the whole dance
floor fighting and for some reason the
room seems to split this group a lots o
big lats bodybuilders on the on that
piss you know stag do it's about 30
sooth a through even the align
themselves up at the bottom end of the
venue looking up towards the door stuff
it would allow themselves up at the top
end of the venue I think I was probably
one of the times that I did feel a bit
of fear that you know this isn't going
it's not gonna go well we were
outnumbered and we all just running each
other and it was just there was no
trying to get anybody out it was a pure
fight it was just a fight she didn't
know who was studying from here he was
still in this idea to his behind you any
one time because that many bodies
involved you knew if he went on the
floor
you guessed I'm solo so it was a case of
survival
stay still him as hard as you could
eventually the police are out side
mopping up dragging people out pulling
in advance because that's era when it
was done there's several of them on the
deck was several of our lads on the deck
as well and you look back at him you
think and then I walked away from that
do I want to carry on doing this job
what's the biggest fight you've been
involved with there was four of us and
we'd patrol the town center basically
and we'd respond to the pub calls that
come up with resistance and they're
nowhere about fifteen blokes who run in
someone who were topless in the middle
of the street by was ever cross in just
swinging seven pounds of [ __ ] out of
each other and then I remember seeing
this one lad get thrown to the floor
quite close to us and score start
stamping on his head it's vicious
they won't do harm either then sort of
come up face to face this guy and bear
hug him got nothing I've looked I've
looked to me right and honestly boy the
distance between mean you are it pulled
out this gun from his waistband and
pulled up and I froze at that point it's
a split second some reason this guy
dropped his gun I don't know if he
fumbled of it on the draw or somebody
pushed him or what
and this this gun had landed on me foot
I bent down and grabbed this gun
I never held it my phone wasn't blow the
trigger guard and I hand over the barrel
I've turned round and the street had
emptied of no one there apart from my
three colleagues and their oven Chavez
is laying flat on the deck like insanely
Finn I didn't think to get on the radio
I was frozen with fear I can believe
that it's gonna me and I've never been
more scared than that in my life and
that's quite early on so has anything
happened to you that I've made that made
you think I could've been killed
plenty yeah so on a local well-known
crack pile of a venue in Black Hill you
know we cleared the beer garden that
would have gone inside about 20 past
10:00 at night suddenly these headlights
appeared the gate pulse of the big on
and carrying on coming the first we
thought was a taxi turning around
no it was this crazy lunatic any BMW
driving at the door he was trying to
kill us all so obviously we were all
backed up inside and he hit the door
pulse bunk he's in a mess in his car we
dragged him out and I'm making I got out
in before the police got all of him the
sort of incidents and you think man I
got on that night described people in my
clubs in three words bunch of there you
know they think they have the right to
do and say whatever they want when I get
quite a lot is I'm a law student or I
know my rights
we don't drag them out because your
fight in fines meant to be outside if so
that he doesn't hurt him and he's safe
and her either than her in a nice safe
what's the worst injury you received
from working the door I've been very
lucky the worst things you have receive
just been a bottom champagne sort of
wine glasses back at the ED I broke my
own hand I'm gonna get somebody to
correct many years ago broke surimi no
calls your normal injuries you know
black ice
nobody's ever managed to break my nose
Donna why lost a couple of teeth when I
first started out men were men and they
fought fists the first these days it's
easy carrying their knife he's gonna
move the bowl he's gonna admit it smash
the glass in my face plenty now it's
pulled out nine times like its own if
you approach him they bottle him run
away but of a set-to with some Lutz one
of the guys pulled a knife he's longer
forward up towards me with it and I was
instantly on to grab the blade Jim Hunt
see this Carla mmm
and he's come through morning's muhammd
and come to the back like an exploded
sausage for the night that's a carry on
working because we were short month
anyway cleaned it cluster on it and
carry on but when I started there was no
training you etem and you were to Maude
you met sure they went down and then you
keep the blade away from him or you
backed up and hopefully one of your
colleagues came up behind him and
hopefully you never arrested your voice
is your main weapon talk to them first
I've had a few people realize that I'm a
bit apart from young good but too nice
but you soft-spoken but do friendly you
can be too polite just be I won't say
loud but be a bit louder than them I've
always said to any of my stuff always go
in nicely because if they then want the
ante and become more aggressive you can
escalate it and it continues if you go
in full steam ahead being a complete
[ __ ] you've no back foot so people like
but be firm and they sure they know
you're in charge not them
can you tell he was gonna kick off just
by looking at them other times I've
looked at people have gone I would like
him he's definitely do something and
then either you've done anything but one
I'd say 100% you can see someone walking
down the road and you can look at him
and say high-risk I tend to try and
engage anybody coming to my door
and a bit of conversation because if
they want to avoid the conversation you
know there's a problem
well if you've got an existing situation
we've got a few people fighting and you
know I deal with quite a few people or a
massive guy that you're thinking and
we're gonna be able to do it what's your
way past that I was giving you our
advice myself look for the one this
landing punches and I mean landing
punches not just throwing wild punches
that guy can fight he's the one you need
to check out straightaway because he's
the one who's going to cause you damage
at times I'd turn the little angers up
will fade always walk in situation you
run into a situation you're not locking
oh what's going on you're not seeing it
was on the outside of it
you're not saying who's we're doing what
but you gotta be I start to learn to
read people and that comes with
experience it comes with time what do
you love most about the work being part
of a team being part of a team
every team knits it's it's a good team
you got good floor workers I got us
playing trouble you got your dog dogs
also : and then you've got your
scrappers the ones that you know he goes
pear-shaped they're the ones that are
going to be waiting in and dragging
these people out I like the little
victories the smile from someone the
thank you
the handshake that's what I enjoy about
it that the human interaction and
showing someone I'm not a an oath have
you ever thought about quitting the job
yeah quite early on my mental health was
starting to get a bit iffy me my
colleagues were on main high street lot
of pubs and clubs and bars and
and nowhere loads of people started
running through this anyway on to the
high street screaming better this young
lady grabbed me and said he's killing
him
I made the choices to go in and this
blokes got another bloke in a doorway
and what was machete in his hand there's
a big machete and we were just hacking
at his head and there's so much blood
and he he just loved his machete and
both weeds about three of them
I didn't bother chasing them I was
always [ __ ] scared
there's nothing I could have done you
don't think the jobs effects in you but
it is and you get older you just
generally get used to it you know it's
coming and it makes you wonder is it
worth it
is the job worth it you've got to be a
certain kind of animal simple as that
it's got to be within you to be able to
do it cut with it deal with situations
not just physically but mentally I
suffered previously now yeah I was
diagnosed there March last year thirty
years is a long time you're wearing sir
you get pulled pushed hit
and it soon adds up do you see things
that other people won't see you do
things other people don't have to do I
had told the young girl's head together
after she had a bottle pull through it
last day with me a long time a long time
just seen how human beings can show you
each other and that's part but I hardest
parts of the job I'm good to me yeah
it's been a pleasure
stay safe and just watch about
the unexpected deaths are always a bit
more difficult and the deaths of people
that don't have anyone so they might be
the last of their family or the family
or abroad and things I think I feel
those sort of data more